your 93-year-old grandmother has seen
this yeah she has yeah and she also
watched Bridgerton too yeah she did yeah
what's that conversation with Nana like
well I tell you with Nana because I know
how I'm watching it I'm like oh oh oh oh
god oh oh I mean I don't know what
happened to me I used to be so
cool she um yeah I mean she says you
know it's not quite like how they used
to make them when it comes to Bridgeton
but when it came to her watching
episodes one and two I had known she'd
watched it she said she was going to
watch it on Paramount plus and my sister
had come over it was my mom's birthday
and I just sent my sister in for lunch
and afterwards I asked her I said you
know how you know what did Anna say and
anything about the intimacy scenes and
she just said um I didn't know he had it
in
him I like
her